getting to the end of Project Runway
they start to eliminate people it
doesn't margarita got eliminated so has
three left
Kentaro me Brandon Brandon he's like the
sweetheart the whole season and so
Brandon gets eliminated so holy crap are
they gonna give it to me I grew up in a
very small and tight-knit Muslim
community in upstate New York I'm number
eight of 11 children we were poor so all
of my clothing was hand-me-downs from my
older sisters so I would put my own spin
on things
cut hemlines add ruffles or what have
you I actually sold my first garment
when I was 10 years old
that was that was definitely a little
kid fashion design and being a quiet
child I just found that to be a way that
I could scream really really loudly I
guess I was like Muslim and so like I
had to get married I was 19 when I met
him 20 when I married him he had just
gotten a new job and I ended up leaving
school and I moved to Tennessee I was
scared I was sad and I was not fulfilled
because I wasn't doing something that I
loved I had a gift and you know I was I
wasn't in the driver's seat of my life
and it was really tough when I I know
it's just sewing but honestly it's the
one thing that I do that I know what the
outcome will be I'm sorry I didn't plan
to cry okay if there are there's some
tissues there I think right and so my
husband and I were on the same page and
we eventually got divorced
I was supposed to be studying anatomy
and physiology but I was actually
watching YouTube videos and I came
across a designer named bra busy and her
work was so good I decided actually at
that moment that I was gonna you know
get in the driver's seat pursue my
design degree and I was going to take
control
Project Runway was the biggest emotional
roller coaster of my life one second
you're super excited Mexican you're so
scared like I need Tim Gunn to love me
that's very important these are the
people that you want to critique you
because what they say goes in the
fashion world on Project Runway shared
our pictures of the cast one comment was
like oh if she puts that symbol of male
oppression on the girls then I'm not
watching this is not Project Runway
International what is going on I thought
to myself like that's what they're
saying now but when they see how well
I've kicked butt on the season it's
gonna shut them all up and it did the
very first challenge I wanted it to be
very very apparent who was in the
building and just seeing her and you
know walking down the runway she's
wearing her hijab its trailing behind
her she's got that Project Runway sign
behind her moments like these are so
meaningful Dianna I learned so much
during that time you know to step out
and to just be free making some really
outlandish things to follow a certain
guideline of dress but at the same time
be fashion forward and be trendy and
feel young and feel beautiful the judges
loved it
I had you know older woman young women
coming up to me and saying you know
thank you we love this or just please
keep pushing forward like we really need
this I was just doing me I was having a
great time and it just so happened that
I was a Muslim girl
fast forward to New York Fashion Week
New York Fashion Week Tim Gunn and me
watching my work on the screen my models
are all dressed they look really great
and the finale hijab was so great it was
amazing and I was like bawling after
coming from not having much of anything
growing up you just never know how far
you can go you can build and like you
can make more
[Music]
I didn't win but with being on the show
I was able to get my name out there so
to speak my plan eventually is to be a
household name it's scary but I like a
challenge
[Music]